The Prophet Muhammad
alayhi wasallam told us that whoever
builds a mosque for Allah, Allah will
build for him a similar house in Jannah.
And we know the great reward that will
not only be gained, but rather will fill
your grave after your death.
Whenever someone prays there, whenever
someone gives Shahada in the masjid,
whenever someone learns something in the
masjid. Yes. That will be something that
you have on your scale.
[Music]
As-salamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh. How are you guys doing? And
welcome to a short episode where I am
joined with an esteemed guest, Dr. Ahmed
Maglad, who is an activist and also a
medical doctor,
a person who's actually been in the
political scene in Sudan himself, a
person who's entrenched in what's
happening. He's got first-hand
knowledge. And it's a matter that we
need specialists and people who know the
matter to tell us about. So, thanks for
joining me, Dr. Maglad, on this very
important episode.
I want to ask you first and foremost to
introduce what is going on for the
layman. What What exactly is this war in
Sudan? And when did it start? Why did it
happen? And then go into specific
details as to what's happening now.
There is no civilian war for sure in
Sudan. This is the most myth available
about Sudan that people
sort of talk about. There is an invasion
in Sudan. Sudan is currently being
invaded by
a UAE-led coalition
made of multiple countries. Some are
even European countries that are
involved in the catastrophe, the worst
and the most
dreadful
humanitarian crisis in the world. It's
It's It's something that come upon us
because of a lot of things, our wealth,
our position on the Red Sea,
because we of the period that happened
after the fall of the Omar al-Bashir
regime.
We We found ourselves losing control in
our own government, in our own country,
and multi-billion dollar businesses
coming to get involved with countries to
take take take over our country. Pretty
much replace our own people with with
those who are we've never seen. They're
fighting us, people that we don't know,
people coming across our borders from
other countries. Literally seven
different countries coming with a lot of
money that is paid from overseas
countries. It's It's an invasion.
>> you talking about the RSF here? Is this
the Hemedti's forces that you're
referring to?
Yeah, if you go back and and look into
all the data, at least 60 to 65%
of the RSF militia is actually
non-Sudanese. They come from seven
different African countries. Absolutely.
You'll find this in the Wall Street
Journal. Where do they come from?
Uh Nigeria, the Chad, Central Africa.
We go all to South Sudan. This is the
neighboring countries. And then you go
all the way to Colombia,
recruited right from Dubai. Habibi.
Dubai, the wealthy city that comes in
this small wealthy country that produces
a lot of arms that kills us nowadays.
Hemedti's forces
What's being said is that they're
committing a genocide now, in fact. And
they're committing it against the
non-Arab population. To what extent is
this correct?
That is 50% correct. They're not only
targeting non-Africans or non-Arab,
sorry. The Africans that are non-Arab.
They're also targeting Arab tribes that
are not,
you know, sort of
accepting their ideology. They are
targeting Yeah, what is their ideology?
Sudanese people. Our ideology is to kill
until you take over the city. You kill
until you until you take over the
villages. You kill until you take over
all the places where they can get
gold, they can get access to the arms
supply. They need the border for for
that with Libya, they need the border
with Chad. They They We've been We've
been under this I'm I'm I'm thanking the
world for waking up and remembering
Sudan over the last week, but this been
happening since the 15th of April 2023.
Khartoum city,
it's not about non-Africans only. I know
the people is talking only about El
Fasher. Khartoum city is a city of a
population of more than 10 million.
Currently, there's only less than 2
million, just short of 2 million people.
10 million has fled that place because
it's not livable anymore. Khartoum is
the capital of this country. It is not
livable anymore. They targeted water
supply, they targeted electricity
sources, they targeted hospitals.
Literally, we have lost pretty much 95%
of our hospitals in all the places where
the RSF present.
They targeted everywhere where humans
can live.
Okay, I mean, this is
a very tragic thing. And as you
mentioned, I think that we have been
We've been really not doing our job in
terms of highlighting the plight of the
Sudanese people
and the humanitarian
aspect of things. Obviously, because of
the news, I guess, in Gaza, which is
also very horrific and tragic news.
I want you to explain what's new going
on now in El Fasher. You've mentioned
that you alluded to it.
Um
We We heard some months ago that the RSF
was pushed out of those regions, and
that we thought that it was going to be
some kind of
resolution from that perspective. Now,
they're building their way back up. And
they are taking the land again. So, what
new developments have happened recently?
And why have they happened?
The Sudanese army is well supported by
the vast majority of the Sudanese
people. I can tell you 99% of the
Sudanese people supporting the Sudanese
army. The Sudanese army were that far
from defeating this militia. They They
got kicked out of Khartoum, they got
kicked out of the whole Al Jazeera
region, one of the largest with the most
populated. They were kicked out of
Sinnar, that's another very large-scale
state and and and geographically and and
very well-populated
area. The The Sudanese army advanced
really well and almost declared defeat.
I mean, the RSF almost declared defeat.
Then the UAE came again to
I guess to resuscitate this militia.
And all of a sudden, this militia got
countries' sort of arms and not
militia's arms.
The The The missiles, the drones, the
smart drones that goes thousands of
kilometers,
and then they started hitting all over
Sudan, starting from Port Sudan, where
the government currently operates,
they they they targeted airports, they
targeted hospitals, all the way to the
northern part of Sudan, eastern part of
Sudan, central part of Sudan. This is
not a militia's ability or capability.
It got
a lot of support. We all of a sudden
found Colombian Colombian, um,
you know, mercenaries available in
Sudan. And even the Colombian president.
How
How many Colombians are there? Like, and
where did they come from? And how did
they get there?
The Guardian report says there about
trainees
available there to train
on the use of drones, to train on the
use of smart, you know, technologies
that can be used during the war. And
also they were available on site in
Libyan border to train. They were found
and a lot of videos appeared on their
presence in in inside El Fasher city,
where this catastrophe unfolding. And
around El Fasher in Nyala,
there about 80 of them that has been
killed and their bodies were in Sudan.
Yesterday, there was an interview with
the Colombian president, and he admitted
that they are getting
recruited from Dubai and Miami. So,
who's winning this war right now?
If you look on the ground, what's
Does it seem like the RSF is is gaining
ground again? And that they're a threat
they could take Khartoum maybe in the
next couple of months? Or is it looking
like there's being there's a response by
the
the government and that they're able to
kind of push them back? What What do you
think's going to happen next?
The army has already made made it to
almost a complete,
you know, end of this war by defeating
this
militia. But what we've seen over the
last,
I would say, 3 months is that the scale
of arming this militia, the scale of
support
of like foreigners,
you know, mercenaries that are crossing
our border is is unprecedented. It's
If you If you look into the amount of
flights that are landing within the army
the the RSF controlled areas Nyala
Airport. There at least two to three
every day that carry a lot of arms
cargo. And and if you look into the
bordering Libyan army bases and and and
airports and Chadian ones and Sudanese
ones, we see at least an average of four
to seven planes every day that full of
arms. This been happening daily for the
last three to four months coming right
from within the UAE. So when you look at
this, they're not arming a small
militia. They they they building a huge
militia to not invade only Sudan. They
looking beyond Sudan. And I'm here
talking about literally by the word
Egypt. The the next in target if you
look into the map, Egyptian land is is
is is pretty much got into this glitch
between the Red Sea where they they they
have full control. I mean the UAE. And
then this is the only border where they
will attack Egypt is the southern port
border with Sudan.
They currently as we talk Muhammad
Hijab, they are at the border at the
Egyptian border with a an ongoing
increasing supply there army supply. It
is putting not just risk at the Egyptian
people and the Egyptian army. It's it's
it's actually pre-invading Egypt. I
would call it. It's a pre-invading Egypt
status. So I think the world has to come
to a strong position to stop this
militia. Well, you you could argue that
them you know doing that would be not
favorable to them because
I mean obviously if if they attack Egypt
then Egypt's bound to respond and
I mean it's you know not going to help
their effort in trying to take over
Sudan, is it?
It
the one thing that you possibly heard
about Bol is Donald Trump's
you know representative to African and
Arab countries. I don't know this is a
new position.
He's his his his brother-in-law or his
advisor to the Arab and African
countries. He actually told us four days
before Al Fasher fallen that we have to
be ready that Al Fasher will be taken
away. As if he knew everything. He
planned everything. He supported
everything. And that was
heart-wrenching for the Sudanese people
unlike
what you're looking for. We have been
talking for the last two years. Al
Fasher city was surrounded by the RSF.
We were talking that if the RSF goes in
a genocide will take place. It it was
very expected. Everyone knew that and
the UAE
did nothing covered that.
The USA covered that also did nothing
waited for it to happen and it happened
and a genocide took place. And it
reports that it's a genocide taking
place against the non-Arab population or
who is it taking place against exactly?
It's it's taking revenge. The RSF tried
to go into this small city Al Fasher.
It's not a small. It's a it's a medium
to large city. They tried to go into
this city for the last two years and a
half and they got defeated at the doors
of this very
I would say important city
geographically and and from a strategic
point of view.
The Hemeti lost most of his cousins at
the borders of this city. Hemeti lost
his major generals at the borders of
this city. So he's got a revenge to take
place.
And that's exactly
absolutely personal for him. He lost his
own cousins there.
So what's he doing? Just
I mean we are seeing very horrific
videos happen you know on on social
media. People being
like tortured like things that you would
think
you would think that the Spanish
Inquisition's happening again. It's like
dreadful images and children as well
women. It's absolutely abysmal.
It's like
let me describe it Muhammad Hijab. I'm
sorry to interrupt you. For the Sudanese
people is like
visiting this and and watching an old
movie again. It's this happened 2003 and
since 2003 happened multiple times
throughout the years in and out in front
of the whole world that they go in. They
burn small villages. They take away
women. They take away
kids and I'm talking here about kids
below five years of age because if you
are six and above, you are a man to them
and you can be killed easily.
They collect all the men into lines.
They shoot them in the head one by one.
And this is what they like doing and
they like to record themselves and they
like to chant their own chants and they
like to enjoy seeing the bloodshed. What
kind of chants do they
chant?
The problem is
they they they use some sometimes Allahu
Akbar and you would think they are
Muslim. They absolutely has nothing to
do with that. They have their own chants
where they declare defeat of the
Sudanese
country the 1965 as they call it where
Sudan took
its own independence. They want to
defeat this country and they want to
destroy the Sudanese army.
If you look into the army what do they
want to put in its place?
The militia. This is the UAE project is
to destroy the Sudanese army. Do they
consider themselves to be Sudanese
themselves? What that how do they
self-identify?
I will use the word in Arabic. It's
called the Attawa country the new Attawa
country. It's
a group of tribes that are Arabian
tribes. They see themselves are more
superior to the African tribes. They
they see themselves more superior to the
northern
Arab sort of tribes. They see themselves
owning this land.
On what basis do they see that?
Why do they see themselves
superior?
For years they've been coming in and out
of Sudan to to sort of do business leave
get support and and they leave in and
out of Chad Central Africa Nigeria
and and all about this region. Most of
them they lived in Sudan peacefully. But
the problem is once this militia took
over and and and this is the big mistake
that Omar al-Bashir left for Sudan. This
was his gift. He made them into a small
sort of
even agreed that on the part his
parliament his is not wasn't a Sudanese
parliament. He made them into a an
organized sort of paramilitary group and
and that's when they got this the arms.
They started doing the dirty work for
Omar al-Bashir. And all of a sudden we
found the UAE found a very good friend.
I think the UAE is lacking an army. They
want to build an African army that is
cheap to run easy to take everywhere.
They can commit any atrocities at your
order and and they're ready to kill
whoever you want at a very cheap price.
And and that's what we see. They they
took this RSF militia to Yemen. They
they they took them to the side of Libya
when they they wanted more support with
Haftar. They they want this African
army under the governments of
UAE.
They don't care how bad they are where
they come from. They wanted a land for
this group of people and they found
Sudan. Let's destroy Sudan. Let's empty
Sudan from its people. Let's put these
people there. And guess what? We can
find gold. We can find
a base that next to the Red Sea and we
can pose risk at Egypt and and across
the Red Sea is only Jeddah the Saudi
Arabian important city. So they they
pose risk everywhere.
And
in terms of the humanitarian aspect now,
are there charities operating on the
ground because a lot of people want to
be you know charitable. They want to
help out.
Have you heard of or do you know of any
charities that are actually operating on
the ground? And if if not, how else
could somebody kind of help out with
this cause? If they want to help out
Sudan, what should they be doing? People
that are listening to you right now.
I really want to use your platform
Muhammad and send a word
a word to the world. Um
we actually
dying for the last three years. This is
the largest catastrophe humanitarian
catastrophe in the world. I'm using the
UN the United Nation wordings.
Famine is not there, but it is
pre-famine, but we do have famine
pockets where we don't know what's going
on. The RSF is blocking passage to
all types of
humanitarian support.
We do have the largest displacement
crisis in the world also. We've got an
an average of 25 to 30 million displaced
people within Sudan and outside the
neighboring countries
outside Sudan to countries.
We do have a large scale catastrophe.
And and
we we suffer per day. We have zero
hospitals that can support the Sudanese
people. When I say zero because what we
talk about is even if we have an open
hospital, they have zero supply or very
limited supply that they can't help
people with. They help them just to come
and die.
We we
if you if you talk about food and and
water, um
there's no safe water. Um the the food
shortages is the the the criteria of the
Sudanese living now, I say. One meal a
day, you're a rich person. If you have
one meal a day, you're a very rich
person. Um
And this is unfolding per day. I want to
also say one more thing. Yes, so
just before you continue,
so people want to contribute, they want
to help, right? So they
How can people help at home now? They've
heard what you've said, they're
completely uh saddened by what's going
on, they really want to help.
What what do they do? We have a lot of
Sudanese initiatives. We call it the
Sudanese kitchens. Um and and the
kitchen is is about um collecting money
for uh just the way you've seen it in
Gaza, where people they they have a a
small, um you know, outdoor kitchen to
to make any type of food that can help
the locals to eat. Uh one meal a week or
two meals a week, per se. Uh we do have
a lot. Um there are some initiatives um
available out there um to to help and
support. Um
Saudi, Qatar, and Kuwait has been uh
opening their doors to collect charities
to help Sudan, and we really thank them
for that. Um even Egypt has been uh
providing some uh humanitarian support
to their ability, very limited. Um we do
have a huge shortage. Um uh if if we
talk about the reputable um
sources, there are very limited options
out there um
to to support Sudan, honestly.
But raising awareness like the way we're
doing now, I think is the first step.
And uh
I really want to thank you for
contributing and enlightening and
elucidating and educating
uh the public, um
Dr. Ahmed. And uh if people want to
follow you, are you uh available on
social media?
I am available on uh
um X, as we call it now, not Twitter
anymore. Um I'm available on social
media. Um but I I we do have links to uh
the charities that are working on uh on
on site in Sudan. Um I'll be reposting
and reposting with with all my friends.
>> What what's your handle on X, um?
MCLAD84
Beautiful. Well, well, thank you so much
for coming on the show. We needed to
raise awareness. I think everyone that's
listening to this has a good image now
of what's happening in Sudan, and we
need to educate ourselves um
in what's happening in Sudan. It's Sudan
is a Muslim country, okay? And people
are suffering there.
Uh and even if you have non-Muslim
population in Sudan, it's a humanitarian
crisis. And if we're going to talk about
genocides in Palestine, if we're going
to talk about the Gaza genocide, then we
have to be fully consistent and talk
about the genocides that are happening
not to the Arabs, but by the hands
of the Arabs, unfortunately, this time
uh in other parts of the world. That's
the only way we can be consistent.
That's the only way we can be uh true to
our faith in helping everyone equally,
no matter where they're from, as the
prophet said, sala Allahu alayhi
wasallam, al Muslim lil Muslim kal
jasadil wahid, that the Muslim to the
Muslim is like one body. Aw kal bunyan
yashuddu ba'duhu ba'da, he's like a
wall, and they all come together. This
is the first step. We hope to do more
initiatives where we speak to different
people with different perspectives of
what's happening in Sudan, people on the
ground, people like Dr. Ahmed, who's
he's been fantastic today as well in
explaining what's going on. Wa jazakumu
Allahu khairan. Wa assalamu alaykum wa
rahmatullahi Hey, you. Are you wasting
your time on social media again? Your
brothers and sisters in Islam net from
Norway are establishing a masjid, a
dawah center. Establishing a masjid to
convey the message of Islam is one of
the best deeds a Muslim can do. There's
a huge need for it in Norway. You know
this, and I know this. So that makes the
reward even greater. So give generously,
and Allah Azzawajal will give you even
more.